bonsoir à tous et merci de nouveau de
nous retrouver pour ce nouveau numéro de
kiosques votre magazine culturel sur
saint quentin en yvelines et ses
environs tout de suite le sommaire de ce
mercredi 27 janvier
kayhan est championne du monde de jeu
vidéo avec plus de quarante trois
podiums incarne la nouvelle culture du
jeu vidéo en france elles étaient
présentés hier lors de l'inauguration du
studio de motion capture à l'école
troisième d'elancourt rencontre avec
cette jeune athlète électronique
aurélien de maison chargée des publics
et de la médiation pour la ville de
guyancourt et en plateau pour nous
parler des deux expositions actuellement
présenté à guyancourt
celle de frédéric vincent et une autre
d'ernest pignon-ernest grand prix de la
sacem du jazz 2011 baptiste trotignon
vaut bien l'art du trio avec itt son
nouvel album
il était hier soir prisme d'elancourt
pour un concert de jazz aux ballades
mélodiques et méditative le jeu vidéo et
le bien culturel le plus offert
aujourd'hui devant le livre la vidéo et
même la musique une industrie
florissante et créatrice d'emplois qui a
généré en 2015 une augmentation d'un
chiffre d'affaires de 11%
nous sommes allés rencontrer l'une des
nouvelles figures de cette culture
alternative kayane images de fanny
bourdillon elle fait partie des 44 % de
femmes amatrices de jeux vidéo sur les
35 millions de gamer en france en 2015
passion héritée de ses grands frères
kayane découvre soulcalibur à l'âge de 7
ans gameuse professionnel aujourd'hui
elle a été présentée hier lors de
l'inauguration du studio de motion
capture de l'école audiovisuel troisième
d'elancourt l'une des premières filières
de formation professionnelle de jeux
vidéo en france
une chance pour tous les gamers selon
elle là on nous donne une formation pour
être dans la création née se trouve ça
vraiment magnifique puisque on a
vraiment un beau talent en france dans
le dans les jeux made in france
on peut réussir à l'international et ce
qui me pousse à croire ça aussi c'est le
succès qu'a eu le jeu life is strange
par le studio dans ce mode qui est basé
en france qui a réussi à conquérir
tous les tous les joueurs du monde
entier parce que c'est c'est la touche
française qu'on retrouve dans le jeu
vidéo et qu'on a du mal à retrouver dans
les blockbusters qui se ressemblent tous
maintenant athlètes électronique chez
red bull kayane est aussi animatrice de
télévision sur game one dans l'émission
gay - esporte depuis octobre 2012
les sports une discipline qui lui a
permis de développer dépassement de soi
fair play et sens de l'entr'aide parce
que je me dis que même si moi je joue à
un jeu de ceux jouant en seul en solo
c'est à dire que je dois jouer tout seul
contre mon adversaire c'est pas un jeu
d'équipé mais je peux pas vous
progressez c'est l'autre est moyen quoi
je dois l'aider à progresser pour que
moi même je devienne plus forte et c'est
toutes ces valeurs là qu'on retrouve par
exemple dans le sport que je les
retrouve dans dans le jeu vidéo
cette jeune spécialiste des jeux de
combat a été titré par l'édition 2012 du
livre guinness des records comme le
record féminin mondial du jeu vidéo avec
43 podium son secret l'approché féminine
plus sensible des jeux vidéo
le fait de pouvoir jouer d'une façon
différente aussi peu perturbé les autres
joueurs qui sont habitués
certaines réactions quand on a
un moment qui est assez répétitif
nous on peut pas réagir du tout de la
même routine donc voilà ça peut apporter
quelque chose de différent dans notre
gameplay
à seulement 24 ans kai est née de son
vrai nom marie laure north wind entend
bien défendre la reconnaissance du jeu
vidéo comme nouvelle culture française
une industrie créatrice d'emplois dont
le chiffre d'affaires a connu une
progression de 11 % en 2015
sans transition du jeu vidéo à l'art
urbain pour nous en parler
aurélien de maison chargée des publics
et de la médiation pour la ville de
guyancourt est en plateau bonsoir
bonsoir
alors donc sont présentées actuellement
deux expositions à vue en cours celle
d'ernest pignon-ernest présenté dans la
salle d'exposition et celle de frédéric
vincent dans la mezzanine de l'hôtel de
ville jusqu'au 6 février pour la
deuxième donc on va faire le
prolongement dans un premier temps avec
la culture alternative on va démarrer
avec l'exposition d'ernest pignon ernest
donc c'est un artiste né en 1942 c'est
un peu le précurseur de l'art urbain
fondateur du street art
ça a été le premier à investir les
villes de l'art est une façon pour lui
de dénoncer la reconstruit pour les
musées c'est à aurélien absolument oui
c'est en effet un des premiers artistes
qui a investi vraiment l'espace public
pour sortir de ces musées de ces lieux
construits pour la contemplation
d'oeuvres d'art et donc des sortes de
deux temples sacrés et pour mettre à
l'honneur donc des ces dessins qui
permettent donc ces passants de
découvrir ses personnages ses figures
qu'elles soient anonymes ou ou donc
connu mais à la fin des années 60 c'est
vraiment donc un des tout premiers qui a
été suivi donc par une toute une
génération plusieurs générations même de
d'artistes qu'on a appelée maintenant il
street artiste ou artistes urbains oui
en effet face ou dos partagez là avec le
tout public est ce que c'est pour cette
raison que vous avez voulu mais rendre
hommage
oui c'est un artiste qui on peut le
référé en effet le mettre en lien avec
cette scène de l'art urbain mais il est
avant tout un très grand artiste du 20e
et du 21e siècle grand dessinateur qui a
un art vraiment engagé il on peut dire
qu'il a vraiment une éthique artistique
depuis toutes ces années
depuis donc la soixante 1966 et c'est
tout premiers pochoirs qu'il a apposée
dans la région de nice où il était dit
il est originaire et il s'est tenu
vraiment un tout une éthique oui je
dirais un engagement pour l'humain pour
les causes pour les personnes pour les
êtres humains qui ont en souffrance un
peu martyrs de notre société on pourrait
dire qu'ils soient anonymes ou non
et voilà donc ccs à un artiste un très
grand artiste dont on vraiment nous
sommes vraiment fiers de pouvoir
présenter une petite rétrospective
dirait de son travail voilà donc cette
petite rhétorique civ
elle est présentée dans la salle des
expositions jusqu'au 6 mars prochain je
vous remercie vous m'avez fait un très
très beau cadeau vous m'avez ramener le
catalogue de l'exposition donc votre
exposition vous l'avez construite autour
de trois grands thèmes la première
thématique c'est la présence de
l'humanité parce que ernest pignon et
est très sensible aux injustices qui en
faisait vraiment un artiste très engagé
absolument oui oui et je précise juste
c'est le catalogue en fait de
l'exposition à la galerie lelong qui
notre partenaire sur cette exposition
qui est sa galerie qu'il représente sur
les prisons notamment la prison de saint
paul à lyon où l'artiste a exposé en
effet sont toutes ces à coller ses
dessins ses reproductions des cent sont
des sérigraphies et
et donc on a pu voilà de travers c'est
cette exposition présentait ce qu'on
appelle des estampes numériques ce sont
des impressions en fait digital qui
réunit donc le les photographies qui
sont les seules traces en fait de son de
son travail des oeuvres in situ dans la
ville ou sur les murs comme ça des
prisons et d'autres lieux du monde
entier où il ya un lien investi qu'il
investit et donc ses dessins également
qu'ils sont associés dans ces estampes
numériques dessins préparatoires
voilà on peut voir vraiment tout le
cheminement tout la création de
l'artiste dans son ses estampes
numériques et qu'il a commencé à partir
des années 2000 ça c'est pour le premier
axe le deuxième axe c'est plutôt
d'inspiration caravage yale voilà on a
vraiment une
on a commencé donc avec l'humanité c'est
la présence de ces de ces êtres humains
anonyme sur tout et on s'est un peu de
chronologique et thématique et
chronologique à l'intérieur ensuite les
références à l'art ancien et notamment
le caravage avec cette très belle série
de 1988 à 90 qu'il a pu poursuivre dans
la ville de naples et donc dé référence
au personnage de 2 du caravage allard
ancien il a fait aussi des références à
rubens à anvers mais la tradition
classique à tradition policier qui
cherchait à promouvoir l'armée de
tradition classique est donc le
troisième axe c'est au tour d'un hommage
rendu aux grandes figures artistiques
qui l'ont inspiré c'est ça donc oui
c'est un artiste qui dans un sens qui
est vraiment dans une grande tradition
de dessins de dessinateurs de dar
classiques figuratifs
mais qui est au service d'une cause et
de personnes je disais anonymes ou non
là ce sont des hommages dans la dernière
série à des artistes des poètes des
écrivains des dramaturges des cinéastes
alors il ya du rimbaud bien sûr il y a
pas seul unique qui
qu'il a occupées encore dans cette toute
dernière série qui a été présenté
l'année dernière enfin tout début
d'année qui s'est terminée il y a
évidemment jean genet dit arthur à
pardon antonin artaud et voilà j'en
passe et des meilleurs et enfin voila
c'est un peu en quelque sorte son
panthéon personnel qui met à l'honneur
dans les lieux des vies de vie de ces de
ses créateurs alors avant de passer à
l'autre exposition peut être un mot sur
les événements annexes à cette
exposition d'ernest pignon ernest
alors oui comme de comme d'habitude en
fait dans le cas de nos expositions à la
salle d'expo on d'exposition on présente
on propose en fait d'un tout un
programme de médiation avec des visites
guidées il y à des ateliers famille est
également là donc une table ronde en
présence de l'artiste avec son ami poète
les andré velter qui fera une lecture
c'est en partenariat avec les
itinéraires poétique de saint quentin
dans la salle d'exposition avec animée
par le journaliste patrick le fur
il y aura sophie pujas qui est une
journaliste écrivain aussi qui a sorti
un ouvrage qui s'appelle poésie urbaine
est également yannick bourseaux le
créateur de la l'urban art fair la
première foire de street art qui aura
lieu au carreau du temple en avril
prochain
le rendez vous est pris une autre
innovation un peu moins réaliste mais
qui fait le pont entre le figuratif et
l'abstrait c'est justement celle de
frédéric vincent
si celle ci est présentée dans la
mezzanine de l'hôtel de ville de
guyancourt jusqu'au 6 février
frédéric 20 soit elle nous propose une
exposition de paysages intérieurs à la
limite de l'onirisme que vous qualifiez
souvent de sublimes
oui c'est vrai que c'est la première
fois qu'on expose frédéric vincent c'est
sa première exposition personnelle à
vrai dire et elle a un travail qui
serait faire je pense au sublime par
cette dimension très onirique qui
propice au rêve
c'est un vrai travail d'introspection un
travail d'introspection qui ne n'est pas
en lien direct avec la nature réelle
mais plutôt à une nature intérieure
on est dans une sorte d'abstraction
peut-être mais une abstraction qui va au
delà on va au delà de l'abstraction elle
a des techniques très très singulière
comme la la poudre de grafite qu'elle
utilise avec son pinceau et qu'elle va
poser sur la toile sur les dessins ainsi
que certaines donc c'est des dessins et
des peintures avec notamment de
l'acrylique mais que de l'acrylique
blanche
enfin cesser cette technique qui est
très original qui voit là est propice
les lui permet de créer ses compositions
très forte et très puissante
voilà aurélien de maison merci d'avoir
été avec nous en plateau et donc je
rappelle the de très belles expositions
à découvrir sur guyancourt celle
d'ernest pignon-ernest à la salle des
expositions jusqu'au 6 mars et celle de
frédéric vincent à la mezzanine de
l'hôtel de ville jusqu'au 6 février
une autre exposition maintenant du 22 au
31 janvier 2016 à la maison de covilha
voisins le bretonneux accueille une
exposition faite par un collectif de
sept artistes peintres et sculpteurs de
l'association art partage en association
avec les résidents de l'établissement
géré handicap
cette association a pour but de
découvrir l'univers de ces artistes
peintres et sculpteurs dans une
dynamique d échanges et de rencontres
hier soir au prisme d'elancourt baptiste
trotignon offrait un concert de jazz
l'occasion de présenter son nouvel album
it un retour aux sources de l'art de ce
trio images de camille lambert
de formation classique au conservatoire
de nantes baptiste trotignon découvre le
jazz en autodidacte ce pianiste de
talent revient à l'heure du trio avec
son nouvel album it
il était hier au prisme d'elancourt pour
un concert mêlant écriture et
improvisation
c'est un album j'avais envie de revenir
au trio piano contrebasse batterie
qu'une formule éternel dans l'histoire
du jazz parce qu'elle permet aux
pianistes notamment de jouer les thèmes
et de jouer beaucoup de cette relation
de complicité qui entre ces trois
instruments
c'est pas par hasard si c'est ça si ça
souvent été jouée par les pianistes
cette formule c'est quelque chose qu'on
a quand même beaucoup tous les trois ans
james thomas révélation française de
l'année aux victoires du jazz 2003 et
grand prix de la sacem du jazz 2011
baptiste trotignon multiplie les
influences musicales du jazz
afro-américain aux musiques du monde un
métissage qui s'attache à défendre
tradition et modernité
je pense que toute modernité 7 c'est un
peu banal de dire ça peut-être mais
toute modernité s'inscrit dans la
tradition dans le respect d'un langage
comme si être langage thaler donc je
tiens à respecter ce langage a joué de
ce langage mais de le dire à ma façon
effectivement avec avec avec ce qu'on
est en 2016 n'est plus en 1985 dix ou
vingt ans donc c'est ça qui est
intéressant ce grand fou baptiste
trotignon est actuellement en tournée
dans toute la france avant de prolonger
l'avanture à l'international
m
parlons musique maintenant en plateau
alba ne perd un bon soir vous êtes
auteur compositeur interprète et ryan
d'amiral vous êtes musicien
bonsoir à vous de alors alba nous avait
tout juste 16 ans et vous avez déjà une
vraie maturité dans la voix je propose
qu'on vous écoute tout de suite
les combats
mais on est soit mais de quoi
soulagement
je
albane comment est ce que vous êtes
passionné pour pour la chanson parce que
vous n'êtes pas issu ni d'une formation
spéciale ni d'un conservatoire c'est bah
écoutez ça tout de suite c'était pour
moi une évidence
donc depuis depuis l'âge de 4 ans je
chante je chante tout le temps chez moi
est vraiment depuis tout petit voilà mes
parents ont nettement entendre tout
enchanté
vous êtes vraiment baignée par la
musique des petites vous avez une
sensibilité musicale
oui exactement j'écoute beaucoup de
musique même depuis petit un jeu voilà
alors ryan vous me disiez quel panier
tête autodidacte et qu'il fallait
qu'elle le reste c'est important pour
vous ça permet de rester plus
authentique
alors je pense qu'il ya plusieurs façons
d'apprendre les choses et effectivement
parfois on peut être un petit peu
comment dire
troublé par l'apprentissage de la
musique notamment dans les
conservatoires et les choses comme ça
donc effectivement je pense que il faut
garder albane c'est une honte point de
vue c'est une une pierre un peu brute et
qu'il faut pas trop polir voilà alors
pas trop polio justement
particulièrement parce que non pas que
vous n'aimiez pas ça mais où vous vous
trouvez qu'on peut très bien réussir et
que presque c'est mieux sans passer par
tous ces fameux télé crochet musicaux
comme ceux voice rising star mais moi je
pense que j'ai eu la chance en fait
d'avoir un producteur enfin compositeur
qui est qui est venu à moi sans que je
demande rien du tout mais après voilà
moi j'essaierai que j'adore regarder les
émissions de the voice mais je pense que
je n'y vois pas de temps après c'est
vrai que la semaine dernière j'ai vu
o'shea qui était proposée pour the voice
et je les ai vues elles mêmes qui
avaient décidé de ne pas faire les
auditions à la veulent exactement ça lui
correspond et par là mais après ce
qu'elle a fait par la suite avec sa
musique où je trouve ça
ça très bien alors tous les deux vous
êtes venus aujourd'hui en plateau pour
nous parler de votre projet musical un
ep qui sortira au printemps prochain
alors un abbé de combien de titres rails
alors allez on va partir sur un enfant
alors le pc indique aux prêcheurs ça
vient du format vinyle c'est céder petit
vinyle voilà normalement c'était maximum
de six titres assez court parce que à
l'époque ont été réduits par là la durée
du format là on va partir sur un cinq
titres
voilà donc on est en train alors on a à
peu près on a travaillé ça fait un
moment qu'on travaille on a on doit
avoir quand même une bonne quinzaine de
compositions donc on est en train de
faire le tri le pc une première phase et
après on souhaite partir sur un album
par la suite voilà donc on travaille
aussi avec un avec gérard qui est du
label le cap et qu'il a avec nous
aujourd'hui et voilà donc on est en
train de travailler sur tout ça pour
voit le ban le plus important dans ce
projet c'est la musique l'écriture
un mélange des deux c'est vraiment
mélange des deux j'ai c'est vrai que la
vallée après rennes et moi en fait
réellement on compose tous les deux
rails animé il met beaucoup en musique
et puis après quand on quand on
interprète en fait j'ai jia libre la
libre interprétation qu des fois j'avais
des idées il en dire ouais c'est cool ça
donc du coup voilà en fait on ajoute
chacun nos idées en fait vous commencé
par composer la musique et l'écriture
vient ensuite c'est ça ouais c'est un
mélange à eau
au départ on travaillait beaucoup comme
ça et puis maintenant on se retrouve
de plus en plus tous les deux autour du
piano elle a fait un petit peu désaccord
tout et des mélodies
c'est assez rigolo comment ça évolue
mais au départ effectivement wade au
départ ça a commencé comme ça c'est à
dire albanais venu chanter sur des
morceaux que j'avais en tête et puis
comme ça se passait très bien voir toute
l'alchimie et puis voilà ça ça a
accroché comme ça voilà et quelles sont
les influences musicales qui vont porter
ce projet alors alors c'est rigolo parce
qu'en terme d' influence on a quand même
un certain écart d'âge
voilà voilà elle pourrait être maman
c'est tout à fait ça
donc au final au niveau des influences
moi j'écoutais beaucoup de choses en
tant que musicien des choses variées
allant du jazz ou hip hop la musique
classique et le rock voilà c'est voilà
et albane me fait connaître plein de
choses des choses nouvelles à adel voilà
qui fait beaucoup de partie de ces
chanteuses ils sont arrivés un peu en
même temps ça constitue évidemment votre
aurait pris votre répertoire de
prédilection
j'essaierai que j'en écoute beaucoup ad
je pense que c'est une image
représentative et c'est vraiment elle
elle a vraiment une belle voix c'est la
loi une fois oui vraiment albane terrain
ryan l'amiral merci d'avoir été sur
notre plateau aujourd'hui ryan je crois
que oui on vous dira merci alors on
voulait remercier toute l'équipe des
violonistes donc on à martin mail i mode
on a également léonie on aimerait
remercier aussi dimitri rouleau galets
photographe ma p'tite julie ma petite
sharlie nama petit noé première fois mes
parents et les gens qui m'entourent qui
sont là pour moi et qui me soutiennent
voilà remerciements et dédicace son
passé nous attendons donc maintenant
votre ep projet musical pour le
printemps 2016 et on voudrait invitera à
ce moment là pour que vous puissiez
venir nous le présente et merci encore
d'avoir été en plateau avec nous
toujours de la musique sur les soignons
sera à l'estaminet de magny les hameaux
à 20h30 samedi soir pour son nouveau
spectacle free un mélange d'humour et de
musique avec un trio funk soul et jazzy
en l'écoutent
ces partis ont tourné tout seul avec des
mecs quand on jette jamais comedy club
suis parti c'était genton en deux ans
c'était comme ça pour vous shafi par les
troupes en tournée
et les mecs ont tombé ça drague d'accord
et quand j'y arrivais pas vers 3 heures
du matin seront tournés vers moi et
regarder comme un immense périmètre
primeau est ce que je ressentais je te
suis du genre à dire dégueulasse que
j'ai fait
si dorota sans transition de la musique
à l'humour et de l'humour au cinéma
comme chaque semaine votre rubrique
cinéphiles tout de suite vos réactions
sur les nouveautés à l'affiché cette
semaine au micro de camille lambert
mais j'ai trouvé que c'était très bien
mais par contre un petit peu 5 décousu
quoi parce que on revoit de certes
certains certaines périodes des saisons
et ça revient en arrière c'est la seule
chose qui m'a déçu mais sinon c'était
bien c'est un très beau film super bien
documenté les images sont exceptionnels
puis va ça fait du bien de voir un film
documentaire de ce genre de temps en
temps un très bon travail de la part du
réalisateur
même si j'ai pas vu ses précédents films
et je branche de mm et je vous super
bien c'est une belle histoire
bon ça flingue dur mais c'est bien ça
tient debout c'est vraiment une histoire
super c'est un film droit qu'une vision
plus sur le chemin
difficulté de vivre mousse sont
intéressants et pour le coup de coeur
professionnels cette semaine c'est luc
beaucoup ont dû signer cette d'elancourt
un coup de coeur du filet set cette
semaine c'est les chevaliers blancs de
joachim lafosse
après à perdre la raison joachim lafosse
nous raconte une histoire inspirée d'une
faits réels interprété comme d'habitude
avec beaucoup de justesse par vincent
lindon
il ya aussi louise bourgoin valérie
donzelli et ça raconte en fait c'est
inspiré de l'histoire de l'arche de zoé
dont tout le monde a entendu parler
c'est donc l'histoire d'une association
soit disant humanitaires qui va en fait
réunir 300 enfants orphelins en afrique
pour les ramener en france tout en
expliquant aux africains que c'est pour
créer un hôpital pour qu'il soit ce
premier qui s'était resta donc c'est un
film assez froid sans concession qui
prend pas parti qui montre simplement
les faits c'est vraiment intéressant à
découvrir parce que ça raconte par le
menu comment les choses se sont passées
donc au niveau de cette histoire de
l'arche de zoé donc avec le très grand
comme d'habitude vincent lindon donc à
découvrir sur nos écrans cette semaine
et cinéma toujours à mme fontaine
revient avec son 14e film les innocentes
qui sortira le 10 février 2016 à cette
occasion le cinéma le roxane de
versailles organise une avant première
en présence de l'équipe et de la
réalisatrice le 4 février prochain à
20h15
le film évoque la tragédie vécue en 1945
par des religieuses d'un couvent
polonais outragé et violées par les
soldats soviétiques
c'est bénédictine vont affronter cette
épreuve grâce à une foi inébranlable
extraits
messieurs
on a tout pour la nation
totalité
rien ne s'oublie
faux
m
combien d'entre vous sont dans cet état
c'est
pour l'eau quand ils ont fait irruption
dans notre couvent ans et l'a été
une horreur et avant de se quitter trois
dates culturel à retenir pour le week
end
vendredi 29 janvier 20h30 venez assister
à la ferme bel ébat de guyancourt
une mise en espace de la pièce un gris
burns à la manière de roméo et juliette
des temps modernes
deux adolescents désabusés manipule
heures par an sur fond de conflits
confessionnels et de suspicion
généralisée de terrorisme samedi 30
janvier à 21h au prisme d'elancourt
retrouver andré dussollier de novecento
l'histoire d'un pianiste né dans les
années 1920 sur un paquebot est aussitôt
abandonné sur un piano dans une boîte en
carton extraits ce fut durant l'été
l'été 1931 jelly roll morton monta sur
le virginia habillé tout en blanc des
chapeaux jusqu'au gant à dia mon petit
doigt par dessus le banc quand ils
allaient des concerts sur les affiches
il écrivait ce soir
jelly roll morton l'inventeur du tueur
et enfin mardi 2 février 20h30 au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines %
ce from the gutter entre burlesque et
chanson des rues le trio londonien
s'inspire de la vie de la môme piaf un
cabaret étrangers noir un voyage
excentrique dans le paris d'après guerre
et c'est la fin du kiosque pour cette
semaine je vous retrouve avec plaisir
dès la semaine prochaine pour une
émission dédiée au 7e art excellente
soirée à tous